so because you guys really seem to enjoy
my video on how to kill Deadpool and
Wolverine I decided to take another stab
at this and have another discussion
about how different heroes could be
killed with this video focusing on
Franklin Richards now I have done a
video on Franklin before and he's also
featured prominently in my videos on
Jonathan Hickman's Fantastic Four so if
you want to know more about his history
you can always check out those videos
but for now we'll take a quick look at
what he's capable of and what makes him
so hard to kill
so as most people know Franklin Richards
is the son of Reed Richards and Susan
storm and has actually been around in
comics since 1968 despite the fact that
he's most frequently depicted as a young
boy while Franklin is a mutant with
inherent telepathy and telekinesis his
ability to work reality hails from the
fact that it's birth proved difficult
and potentially fatal for Susan
traveling to the negative zone in order
to harness an object called the cosmic
control rod Franklin was imbued with his
energies allowing for natural birth
without concern for Susan's well-being
that said what makes Franklin so hard to
kill
well for starters because of his
exposure to the cosmic control rod
Franklin's powers allow him to warp
reality by manipulating cosmic energies
meaning that any thought desire or whim
that pops into Franklin's head can
become real as a result if there's a
person that he does not want to exist
any more he can make that happen on the
other hand if there's a person that dies
and he wants them to come back to life
he can make that happen and was
interesting to note about this ability
is that the upper limits of his power
have not been determined in comics up to
this point but here's what we do know
Franklin is so powerful that he can send
people to parallel universes and bring
them back and has even created a pocket
universe furthermore he can neutralize
the powers of other superhumans
something he was capable of showing when
he constructed a box that negated the
destructive quality of blackballs voice
that he could talk normally and he's
even able to turn energy blasts from a
celestial into a harmless stream of
flowers inspiring a bit of fear and a
lot of concern in the minds of Universal
entities like Galactus and Mephisto now
in addition to his reality warping
powers telepathy and telekinesis
Franklin Richards also has precognition
which allows him to see the most
probable future but only extends a few
days into the future he also possesses
the ability to project energy blasts and
project himself onto the astral plane
and Franklin's also shown himself able
to resist
mental and physical attacks as he's able
to repel the psychic attack of a
celestial as well as withstand one of
the Celestials energy blasts although
this durability likely stems from
Franklin's reality manipulation instead
of some latent durability that he
possesses through a separate power in
addition to this is also been suggested
that Franklin is immortal as he and
Galactus contemplate that when the
universe has been destroyed and reformed
in billions of years the two of them
would be around to observe it having
said that how do you kill someone
that's this powerful well there have
actually been a couple of instances
where Franklin dies in the comics one of
these examples occurs in the x-men event
Days of Future past which centered on an
alternate history where an adult version
of Franklin is killed by a blast from an
Omega Sentinel however because that's an
alternate version of Franklin and we
don't know if his powers in that future
have progressed to the level they have
in the main level timeline the only
option we have here is to basically
table that possibility and focus on his
current version now as we stated earlier
Franklin's power is pretty much on the
same level as the Celestials and so it
stands to reason that any of the cosmic
entities in the Marvel Universe that are
more powerful than the Celestials would
be able to kill Franklin Richards and
this would include entities like the one
above all the beyonders the fulcrum the
molecule man Owen Reese and the Living
Tribunal but because we're talking about
how Franklin can be killed by non
multiversal threats things actually
become a little trickier since Franklin
is able to work reality attacks from
even the most powerful enemies would
prove ineffective if Franklin is shot
for example he can make the bullet the
gun or even the shooter vanish from
existence if someone tries to drown him
he can bend reality to make the water
disappear or he can make himself develop
the ability to breathe underwater now a
possible way to work around this is to
kill Franklin instantly so that he
doesn't know it's coming and cannot bend
reality to cause his killer to vanish
out of existence or make himself in
volleyball at any former fashion
however this entire possibility is
negated because of the fact that he was
a telepath with his telepathy the second
someone thinks about killing him he
immediately knows about it the offset
here though is that he would have to
make the decision to read their mind and
maybe he has no reason to suspect that
they're plotting his demise or maybe
we're talking about an individual who's
a stronger telepath and Franklin someone
like Charles or Quinton choir or maybe
we're talking about someone that's
resistant to telepathy
such as Magneto or juggernaut or even
someone who doesn't technically have a
mind to read like Ultron or the vision
while these individuals could strike
quickly enough that Franklin could not
anticipate their attack either through
telepathy or observation and work
reality in a way to render their attack
futile it also needs to be stressed here
that although Franklin can make himself
into his reality warping ability in his
natural form he has all the weaknesses
of a normal human being and so if
someone were to take him by surprise and
kill him before he realized what was
happening it is theoretically possible
that this could be successful however
this is not a surefire way to kill
Franklin due to his precognitive
abilities since Franklin can see the
most probable future before it occurs
even if he cannot receive an attack as
it happens through telepathy he can
probably see it coming days before it
happens and plan accordingly to thwart
it with this in mind it may seem as if
killing Franklin Richards is nearly
completely impossible but all of these
difficulties stemmed from Franklin's
ability to work reality which we cannot
forget is a mutant power this is
important because there have been a few
different ways in Marvel Comics that we
have seen mutant powers negated in one
form or another one of the ways is
through the inhibitor collar which we
actually see in the Days of Future
Passed online mentioned earlier these
collars are placed around the necks of
mutants to keep them from accessing
their mutant powers and while it's true
that Days of Future past is distinct
from the main Marvel timeline
it doesn't seem out of the realm of
possibility that one of the greater
Minds of the Marvel Universe maybe even
Reed Richards himself could come up with
a similar or even identical invention
now if someone was able to place one of
these devices on Franklin it would
suppress his mutant power to work
reality and make him susceptible to any
attack in addition to an inhibitor
device Franklin's mutant powers can also
be dampened psychically this is evidence
when Franklin as a child advances his
age to adulthood and adopted the moniker
of
avatar the issue with this though is
that even though Franklin's physical age
was increased his emotional and
psychological maturity remained on the
level of a small child because of this
Franklin realized that he wasn't mature
enough to control his powers and so he
transforms himself back to a child and
plays his psychic dampeners in his own
mind it will prevent him from using his
own abilities until he reaches an age
where he can be trusted to control his
powers effectively now the reason why I
point this out is that it gives us
another way to counteract
infants mutant abilities and what this
means is that if someone is a telepath
or has access to telepathy they could
probably use her psychic powers to place
these dampeners in Franklin's mind once
again making him vulnerable to virtually
any physical attack now while that last
option is kind of stretching things the
final way to get around Franklin's
immense power is to actually go through
another mutant named leech
now leech is a pretty obscure character
in the x-men series but he was a member
of the underground group of mutants
called the Morlocks and later he was a
member of the Future Foundation
alongside Franklin Richards
but leeches mutant power is to negate
the powers of anyone within 10 yards of
him no matter if their powers are mutant
abilities magical extraterrestrial or
anything else the way this works is that
leech is able to shut down pathways and
the person's brain and prevent them from
accessing their powers and so if someone
could convince leech to D power Franklin
we would basically arrive back at the
other same scenarios where Franklin is a
normal person and could be killed by
virtually anything but with that being
said we're going to bring this video to
an end and if you guys are interested in
seeing more videos like this make sure
you drop a like and hit the sub button
but also post a comment down below tell
me what characters from Marvel or DC
that you guys would be interested in
seeing a video on in terms of how they
could be killed if they could even be
killed at all for that being said I will
catch you guys on it peace
[Music]
friends daily that I should move
and try and forget
[Music]
son